well welcome to Cara to st. Louis again
for another showdown speaking of
relatively fast time controls you just
had a match with Carlson that didn't go
your way and a lot of people thought you
were just the king of bullet and blitz
or at least online do you think that's
changed or do you think that it was just
a bad day um I mean there are a few
things I think overall I mean
objectively I probably should have won
the match I think based on the number of
good positions that i got which i turned
into losses on so if you look at it from
that standpoint i probably should have
done well i think i mean really the
issue was not converting the chance they
had where I had much better positions or
winning positions and then then in Bowl
it I mean I I won the bullet portion i
probably could have done done better but
it still went to been enough i was
behind by too many games so you know i
think i think it wasn't great but
overall i'm not too disappointing
considering the positions i got it's
just I didn't convert so it wasn't that
bad still the king of bullet I think so
yeah I mean I beat Magnus I I think
maxime probably is a little bit better
than Magnus but but nevertheless I think
I'm still the best but of course bullet
doesn't have a real practical value to
it so i can say i'm the best at it but
it doesn't have there there's nothing
really special about that all right now
a little bit about your style and at how
its progress through the years and
especially do you adjust it to faster
than controls um i think certainly my
style these days is much different than
it was when i was younger as much more
aggressive taking big risks i think i
think the main thing you learn when
you're becoming stronger especially when
you go from say Grand Master maybe 2,500
strengths 2,600 2,700 level is that the
level of risk you intake is much
different I mean you can't just do
things that are outright dubious against
2,700 plus player as whereas I think
even it may be 2,500 level you can do it
and get away with it so obviously my
style is changing I become
much more Universal I think I tend to
play all sides quite well but I'm
Blitzen and wrap it especially I tend to
play things that sometimes are a little
bit dubious just because my opponents
don't have as much time to try and
figure it out